pris soin d'envoyer le film a tout le
monde rit donc tout le monde l'a vu eh
bien ça tombe bien les chéris interro
surprise a à peu près sur le film avec
charlotte et avec amir
attention si j'envoie un soufflé à si
j'envoie un donner la réponse avec le
pied avec le nez avec les mains avec les
yeux ou encore le sort alors je peux
dire quelque chose mais charlotte j'ai
remarqué en regardant l'émission que
c'est quand même toujours un peu le même
qui ne voient pas les films pense à jean
michel maire j'avais vu et j'ai beaucoup
aimé besoin de mireille gamelin
alors on va voir si vous l'avez vu mais
je vous posais pas de questions damas
les vestiaires et on va voir les
chiffres et vous savez quoi j'annule
tout c'est juste pour lui l'intérêt
[Applaudissements]
nous savions que ça n'aura pas besoin à
côté est-ce que je peux suggérer qu'on
repart et de l'argent pour ne rien lui
dire c'est dégueulasse et les bienfaits
voilà vraiment pour un bouchon est
d'aller la comtesse quel est le rang
social du personnage de charlotte
je le dis où j'écris pas maintenant
quand vous êtes tout seul pouvez le dire
montès conteste foutait de ma gueule
non non l'eau et oui charlotte la
réponse manicon comtesse ça démarre
doucement même temps du film salt en
confiance mais aucun jeu mais on sait
qu'il a vu la jaquette
oui son deuxième question et on a un
petit extrait du film charlotte vous
expliquer aussi ce qu'est une
aristocrate à votre personnage amiens
qui t'expliquent nous l'avait donnée
regardez attention et durant une
deuxième question d'un instant le joli
nom mais je vous lis et abbeville vous
répondez bien oui oui si on répondait
bien à toutes les questions doivent
établir dans la vie si vous répondez
bien à toutes ces questions vous
reste-t-il sinon on fait un cadeau ça
oui si vous répondez mal et cela raconte
devant chez moi vous rentrez chez vous
mais j'ai donné rien mais vous croyez
tous les chroniqueurs à bravo mais la
partie des doubles et doubles parce que
c'est oui mais mais la récompense c'est
quoi ce récepteur est avec moi c'est
normal de rester anonyme nous remettrait
aux autorités quand vous serez remis sur
pied en attendant considérez vous comme
assigné à résidence
moi je dis ça parce que normalement les
bouches comme vous ça marche avec les
keufs non les bourges
vous avez dit les bourges va vous errez
mon jeune ami
les bourgeois défendre ce qu'ils
possèdent nous les aristocrates
défendons ce à quoi nous croyons sauver
l'honneur tenir le rang ne pas se
justifier
ne pas se plaindre voilà
parce que tu es ma chérie parce que j'ai
vu ton film que je n'ai noté
alors certes il a une cabine à uv avec
des écrans de sujets réponse fuse je
paye à quelqu un double salaire si j'ai
tout bon vous payer double facile à
passer comme ça l'émir du groupe dont
j'ai moi-même maintenant il faudrait
juste faire votre travail c'est votre
travail de regarder le travail est
devenu la définition de la vulgarité
dans le film il ya une définition de la
vulgarité
si on n'est pas vidéo comme il sait
qu'il est parti j'ai une balance maintes
fois vous le connaissez pas attention
deuxième question d'aller la comtesse
que fait le personnage d'amir à table
avec la salade
il a coupé le son couteau bravo tu as
bananalotto là c'est pas mal et on va
regarder mais oui mais on va regarder
veut le croire
des oeuvres d'art dans le cas des mêmes
spécialistes m'ont accusé d'un succès
même pas moi j'ai rien fait ils disent
tous ça la justice peut se tromper
moi je te crois dites moi bien
vous avez tout à fait raison de coupes
et la salade avec votre couteau même si
cela ne se fait pas assez sympa à dire
comme ça mais moi oui mais moi oui mais
c'est parce que dans le temps d'arriver
au casting en danger des coûts tant
d'argent
hélas la vinaigrette avec l'argent ça
c'est la vie des grecs est très fort
mais maintenant c'est ridicule dont on
peut pas pêcher bien évidemment c'est
bien sûr un mois je savais moi je la
coupe encore là ça vous demanderez oui
mais vous avez bien raison maintenant
élever au moins 10 morceaux et quand on
est arrivé on ferme sa gueule troisième
question là combien en tout 62
questionnant y aura quatre questions
j'ai des quatre questions
4 dans le film il ya une scène où
abdelkader essaye d'apprendre quelque
chose de précis à charlotte
de quoi parle-t-on bailly apprend à
voler dans un supermarché a volé un
supermarché d'atika twins étiquettes de
bouteilles devant la question du wisla
ouais je sais un bon service
c'est pas tout à faire ses lacets la
démarche est à dire je prends je prends
la réponse de mr abe est d'accord je
ferai attention ça va se jouer
maintenant on aura la réponse en images
il a une oreillette ou pas il a pas
d'eau rien mans il a travaillé on sait
le chérubin
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes vraiment dégueulasse
selon les cas il est bien là non
attention d'ailleurs question est
épatant et la beauce et tuez moi j'ai
l'impression est doublement des coûts
tout en aidant cette émission c'est ma
gueule ou quoi si l'on travaille notion
question que fab d'elle quand il est
très énervé pour se calmer chiche si tu
perds ça va chier pour ta gueule parce
que c'est à dire t'as pas vu tout le
film pas moi non plus alors voilà mais
si amiens 1-1 a compris quoi j'y suis un
super soldat questionner samwhan on veut
couvrir c'est andy lui aussi les vicieux
donc là deux méthodes
oui mais nos méthodes alors qu'est ce
qu'on vous dit charles pas répond toi
c'est elle même qui sera maire aimerait
tant on y sert à rien à 2-1 le vol il ya
le il répond par le vol de la bouteille
qui détend il ya aussi la marche
vraiment regardé territoire a compris le
film dans lequel ont tous regardé truc
dont je suis hyper mais ça va pas se
passer comme ça qu'est ce que vous
faites dans ces moments-là vois rien je
me pose je respire je me calme tout
c'est ça vous fait du yoga abdel je vous
demande ce que vous faites quand vous
êtes hyper énervé je crois les chéris je
crois qu'il a vu le film et vous verrez
ce qu'il a aimé
oui beaucoup ça film familial c'est très
bien joué en plus chaudes se trouve ça
très bien et bien bravo
[Applaudissements]
c